asked about negative elements of having  children yeah i feel i think there was  virtually nothing about it that was  negative as far as i was concerned it  was difficult to sort out  how the attention was going to be split  in the household i missed your mother  when she was so occupied with the  infants but  having children more than made up for  that and you know kids get a bad rap and  people think of them as an impediment to  freedom  and it's such a foolish way of thinking  because it's so remarkable to have  children and  you have the opportunity of having the  best relationship with anyone you've  ever had in your life when you have  children  also someone is finally more important  than you